berkshire hathaway's
philosophy and intuition can you
duplicate intuition
can you duplicate intuition like does
trump's kids have the intuition of the
father
you know does can obama teach intuition
to his kids
can elon musk teach intuition to his
four or five kids
you cannot teach intuition so berkshire
hathaway is an interesting place right
now because
90 years old listen i mean people are
sitting there saying we love this guy we
were 90 years old charlie munger is a
little older as well they did the
shareholder meeting in la for a reason
typically they do it in omaha but they
did it in l.a because of charlie munger
so they didn't do the meeting in the
typical place that they do it for
decades
right why because you couldn't travel or
well i mean it's just you know
concerns covets safer much better if we
do three years old yeah i mean you
understand it right so
but the big question to ask is are they
gonna be able to continuously beat s p
500. it's not been our last few year run
i mean he had a good run in 2000s or
1990s or 80s
but there's a difference between 80s 90s
and 2000s and today by the way he's the
biggest shareholder of apple these are
the companies they own today
uh american express biggest shareholder
apple b of a
charter communication coca-cola chevron
gm merck
moody's u.s bangkok verizon you know
you and he's very careful with
technology he barely got into apple like
he was
you know always negative about what
technology is going to do
not bullish on bitcoin yeah for example
i'll give you an idea like right now
baseball cards okay i don't know if you
guys been following any of the baseball
cards if you want to put it up crazy
story on what happened you heard when i
saw my uh
for one point three million two down for
two million bucks they're like oh my
gosh
sold two cards or two million dollars
okay on luka doncic's birthday go to the
other one i sent you
luka doncic he's 22 years old crazy his
rookie card just sold for 4.6 million
dollars
it's the second most expensive card ever
sold he's never won a championship he's
never won an mvp
he's 22 years old he even said himself
in an interview i
i'd like to own some of my own cards
millions are being made
he doesn't make money on these cards he
just got a contract pay me some of these
millions of dollars right
go lower to show the card what it looks
like do you have the picture of the card
if you go up it's uh okay they don't
have it here
go to the other one go to know the other
one i sent you
this guy right here he bought mickey
mantle's psa 10 card for
5.2 million dollars look at the top
5.2 million dollars guys holding the
card right there wow who is this guy how
does he have 5 million bucks i mean he
paid 5.2 million dollars for this car we
need to sell him a luxury
house asap so watch what happened to you
watch what happens here
go to nba top shot okay
i don't know if you guys have been
following this or not okay so
look at the reaction of everybody okay
people have spent more than 230 million
dollars
buying and trading digital collectibles
on nba
highlights a recent highlight okay go on
youtube to show one of the highlights
it's a video you buy for three hundred
thousand dollars
okay like yes exactly let me just show
the card
type in mba highlights uh nft uh uh
uh uh put lebron just put l-e-b-r-o and
yell lebron let's see if it shows
uh one of them just sold for
300 okay say the same thing you typed
and put it in google
same thing you typed and put it in
google okay and i'm going to get to my
buffet point here because it has to do
230 000 no there's one that just sold
for oh right there
click on the second one lebron james
highlight video
just sold for 270 000
guys it's a six second video
go down it's a six second video okay if
they have the video to show go a little
lower let's see if they got it you guys
got to see this here
go lower okay they don't have it anyways
it's a six second video of him
uh duncan you buy it you own the crypto
highlight for 230 000
230 million dollars has already been put
into this this is branch bank you know
that just got started
so it's not cryptocurrency it's crypto
collectible
cards and videos okay so now watch this
i'm being interviewed guys ask me a
question because you know it's a
collectible
genius guy and this last week i spoke to
guys that run
uh the biggest auction and a new thing
called rally put
rally rd i think it's a rally rd you can
officially
buy stocks of cards go to rally rd i
think this is the one
you buy stacks of cards i like this they
bought my wayne gretzky card they bought
it
for 720 000 one of them they have it on
there right now for eight hundred
thousand dollars you can buy a share
for 12 bucks love it oh my god love it
genius idea yes okay and by the way they
don't just do it with cards
they do with paintings they do with
artwork they do it he's gonna come in
down next month we'll have a
conversation with them
rally genius idea rally is a platform
for buying and selling
equity shares in collectibles
collectibles assets
any kind of collectibles artwork
painting
genius if you're like look i'm not
trying to drop 200 grand on a baseball
card
sure cool put in 10 grand and i'll you
get a portion of a zion williams
exactly that's exactly what it is so now
you're in advertising
um things that only the super rich used
to have access to
exactly artwork you gotta i own two
percent of a picasso
which what you just said is exactly how
they sell it
what you just said exactly how they sell
it right so now
what does this have to do with buffett
here's what it has to do with buffett
the guy asked me a question he says so
what do you think is going to go up and
what do you think is going to go down do
you think the physical cards
are going to be bigger or you think
these crypto nft type of stuff is going
to be bigger
i said the benefit i have is i'm 42
years old
is i'm young enough to remember i'm old
enough to
know the value of cards when it was 30
years ago when we collected them and
it's emotional to me
but i'm young enough to be logical to
know this crypto
stuff that you're seeing that's
ridiculous to warren buffett it's going
to take off
this is going to take off so the
challenge with buffett is
is there an age where you hit where some
of the philosophies and the risks that
you took you no longer will take
to outgrow s p 500 i don't know
that's the challenge because remember
you're not buying a physical product
you're buying the man's mind and he's 90
and the other one is 95.
so is berkshire hathaway going to
continue growing after
buffett what do you think i think they
clearly have to have an
exit strategy or a uh succession plan in
place it's not like
god forbid warren buffett dies this week
they're like what do we do now
oh my god they're like our leaders are
in their 90s they're like the the two
guys and like the muffet
the muppet up in the crowd like the old
guys yet like
they have a succession plan in place
clearly like we're not
i wouldn't overthink this i would i
would assume that they have
a plan in place and they understand that
they need to do you know my question
though my question is can you teach
intuition
no i mean you give the example of like
tony robbins son is trying to go out
there and give speeches and you're just
like
you know sorry buddy like you know
michael jordan
exactly like i don't think don jr has
what
trump has you know maybe a little bit
eric certainly doesn't you know
ivanka maybe a little bit uh tiffany no
um we'll see what baron stock is that
but the point is you can't teach
intuition you can't teach what you're
talking about so
um but berkshire hathaway what do you
think
i think i think there's a philosophy
right
and you either have
intuition charisma your own set of
beliefs
and values and experiences and people
follow you for whatever reason they want
to follow you right but
uh with the succession plan if a
philosophy of a company worked out for
decades based on warren buffett's
values and beliefs of investing then
you have to find someone who has a
similar philosophy
but also dares to look at new ways
of for growth opportunities such as
walmart looking into vincent and i just
i think it's extraordinary what you just
said in that
you have to be old enough to be
wise and experienced but you have to be
young enough to know that
things are changing i mean just look at
the
after the advent of google the whole
world has changed right since 2002 or 3.
this is why they're saying that chamath
palapita
is sort of the new school warren buffett
you heard this analogy people are making
this analogy a lot do you know who this
is
chamath he's he's pull him up maybe
she's recognized
he's a very successful uh part small
owner of uh uh or
state warriors he was an early investor
in facebook i believe and he's
he's a billionaire he's and and then
remember that face we're going to sell
him a 25 minute
house i get a 10 report with him we can
sell him a 40 million dollars no you
could actually it's not a problem and he
would actually do what's his net worth
probably yeah he's a bill and a half i
think he's a he's a bill or two billion
guy is he two he's a billionaire guy
what does your net worth need to be
sonata to buy a 20 million dollar house
you need to be worth
100 million 200 million i
like for a 20 million dollar house yeah
and in detail if someone's looking at a
20 million dollar house
like you know all right this person's
worth you know yeah you have to be worth
at least i would say 200 100 unless
exactly 10x unless unless you decide
to um have
not just mortgage but like some people
use asset-based loans
to to finance if they feel very strongly
the the value of the house is gonna if
they consider it as an investment
rather than just a place so if you're
looking at a million dollar house
do you have to have a net worth of a
hundred thousand of the same rules you
need to have less
a little bit different rules yeah so
it's um
because i will say huge majority i was
going to say 99
of of people looking at ultra luxury
real estate
are all paying cash cash 25
and yeah but for people who are looking
at a million dollar property
most of them are actually looking to
finance so that's why it's so different
you only need 20 to put down rather than
you know being 10x okay so
so are you optimistic long-term
berkshire hathaway or no i'm not betting
i'm not betting against warren buffett
no no but wait a minute i didn't say
warming see how i got all you see how i
got diplomatic i know you did yes i am
yes i am you're you're i believe that he
has
uh imparted enough wisdom and knowledge
and principles on the people that will
be taking over because i don't remember
the gentleman's name but we talked about
who the next man up was but i believe
that they
are like you said old enough to
understand
the past but young enough to to move
with the times what do you think sonata
long-term berkshire are you long
berkshire hathaway or short
i oh that's a tough one particularly
knowing what we just discussed
i'm long-term because of the sheer size
and ability to to move through
whatever the market's going to bring and
just look at the companies that
if you're the biggest investor in apple
i'm riding with you
straight up coca-cola and and the thing
is obviously i think it's going to take
a hit once
one or both of them passes away just
emotionally because people are gonna be
like all right i'm out
uh however he has said multiple times he
the the companies that have been chosen
in the past are such
value companies that he said like
essentially a ham sandwich can run them
because they're so
stable companies that don't require a
lot and if those are the ones they own
then i think those will stay valuable uh
long term but however the question is
will they able be able to pick
new companies like that that's where the
issue's gonna be well that's that's
that's the processor of somebody so i
you look how many things you're seeing
right now where the math
makes zero sense like the typical
formula of that was used
20 30 years ago doesn't apply today but
he was the same way during the stock
boom whatever
the dot-com bubble like he he's pulled
out of the
of the market because he says the market
doesn't make sense why don't you go go
to berkshire hathaway stock go to
berkshire hathaway stock history of it
let's take a look at that berkshire
hathaway stock history
it still looks very good i think it's at
350 377
000 right now per share look at that
it's gone up
will it continue going up post buffett
that's the question that
if you want to buy one share right now
you're spending 377
wow to buy one share a share b share is
like 300 bucks but if you want to buy an
asia right now
377 thousand dollars a share eight one
four
one share is three hundred seventy seven
thank you gotta love that though
hey we're not doing splits we're not
doing anything you wanna share spend
that 377
and people where is that what is that on
the most expensive stocks
it's the shares it's standard number one
yeah it's the most expensive
they've never done a split they've never
done it they tell you you want it spend
that 377 and then you'll be invited to
the
shareholder meeting that they're having
can you imagine but everybody that goes
there owns at least one share
back to your point with that rally if
you want to own a percentage of a stock
and you know there's companies out there
like stockpile and
things like that where you can uh you
know have um
one guy buffett ten thousand dollars
back in 1974.
this guy was a small you know this story
we talked about that that
ten thousand dollars he left it never
touched it it's worth 780 today
wow never touched the money so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye